we are told that Andre goes to a movie
that starts at 19 hours 45 minutes or
1945 and is 90 minutes long what time is
the movie finished so pause this video
and see if you can answer that before we
work through it together alright so what
I like to do is set up what we could
call a timeline so if this is our
timeline and let's say that this is 19
hours right over here 19 hours maybe
this is 20 hours right over there and
then this would be 21 hours right over
there
now what time does the movie start it
starts at 19 hours 45 minutes so this
would be 19 hours 30 minutes which would
be halfway between 19 hours and 20 hours
and 19 hours 45 minutes would be halfway
between 1930 and 20 so 19 hours and 45
would be right over there so let me
write that down that is 19 hours and 45
minutes and that is when this movie is
going to start now it's going to
continue for 90 minutes so when does it
end so there's a couple of ways you
could think about it the way I think
about it is it will take us 15 minutes
to get to 20 hours so that's 15 minutes
and so 15 minutes of the movie has
happened by 20 hours and then how much
is left
well 19 minus 15 is 75 so then there's
another 75 minutes left well 60 of those
75 are going to get you to the next hour
so then it's going to be like this so
then you're going to have another 60
minutes to get to the next hour so so
far we've used 75 and then you're going
to need another 15 minutes to have a
total of 90 minutes so then you're going
to have another 15 minutes and so when
does the movie end well as you can see
we started in 1945 15 minutes got us to
20 another 60 minutes got us to 21 so
now we have a total of 75 and then
another 15 would give us a total of
90 so we are finishing 15 minutes after
the 21st hour or after our 21 or however
you want to think about it so this time
right over here is going to be 21 hours
and 15 minutes or 21 15 so that's the
time that the movie is finished